[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí en
france 24 y vamos a abordar una de las
últimas novedades en torno a la
vacunación contra el virus del cob en 19
y sus variantes que preocupa a los
gobiernos a nivel internacional y a lo
largo de todo el planeta en este
contexto la farmacéutica estadounidense
país.el anunció que una tercera dosis de
su vacuna puede impulsar la protección
contra la variante delta del corona
virus frente a un esquema de dos dosis
saludamos entonces al doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
asesor científico de france 24
bienvenidos nuevamente autor presi
cuentos
en qué estado se encuentran los estudios
sobre la efectividad de esta tercera
dosis frente a la variante delta y qué
datos se han arrojado hasta el momento
entonces en esos estudios
hay varios estudios que están digamos en
curso no solamente con la plataforma de
fases sino con otras plataformas para
hacer un refuerzo nosotros nos habíamos
prevenido que desde el inicio que
hubiera sido necesario o será necesario
un refuerzo lo que no tenemos es tal vez
el tiempo el sometimiento que
actualmente la farmacéutica faes él es
que entre 6 a 12 meses después de la
pauta completa de vacunación la persona
recibe un refuerzo y eso incrementaría
el volumen de arctic cuerpos para evitar
la infección por las variantes doctor
esa recomendación apunta a algún grupo
en particular de la población
inicialmente se ha contemplado y se está
haciendo en israel para pacientes
inmunosuprimidos es decir que tienen
como cáncer enfermedades debilitantes
del sistema inmunológico y probablemente
la primera recomendación sea en eso en
personas mayores porque tienen menos
defensas y en personas que tienen
enfermedades médicas que afectan sus
defensas ahí vamos a necesitar priorizar
el reforzamiento de estas vacunas doctor
ante esta información brindada por la
farmacéutica cada país responde con
políticas propias
uruguay por ejemplo anunció que todos
los vacunados con el esquema completo de
la vacuna china sino sinovac podrán
también recibir una tercera dosis de
facer esta combinación de vacunas se
debe a una desconfianza hacia la
producida en china
no es una desconfianza lo que pasa es
que el conocimiento es el que está
creciendo sabemos que las vacunas como
la vacuna de sinovac es una basta una
vacuna bastante efectiva para las
variantes que estaban circulando
disminuyen muy forma muy efectiva la
mortalidad y la hospitalización
probablemente con la detenimiento de
estas variantes se necesite reforzar y
una opción es reforzar o con la misma
vacuna o con una plataforma distinta
cada entidad regulatoria de cada país
está tomando una decisión al respecto
con sus grupos asesores hay otros que
están reforzando con la misma vacuna y
hay otros que están haciéndolo con
plataformas distintas vamos a esperar
las evaluaciones posteriores justamente
para profundizar un poco en esta
pregunta doctor desde su concepto usted
cree que podría ocurrir lo mismo con el
resto de las vacunas o dependerá
únicamente la recomendación de una
tercera dosis del tipo de vacuna
respecto a la forma como haya sido
creado el inoculante
y yo creo que es necesario hacer un
reforzamiento de la vacuna cómo hacerlo
mejor en qué intervalo y si es necesario
intercambiar o hacer
mixta la vacunación con plataformas
distintas es lo que estamos dilucidando
cada vez hay mayor información que a
mayor intervalo de entre la
administración hay mayor eficacia y que
hay algunas opciones para colocar dos
plataformas distintas que también
mejoran la producción de anticuerpos
esto se va a tomar un año unos meses
pero seguramente así va a ser los nuevos
esquemas de vacunación de acuerdo de la
circulación de las variantes y para
finalizar doctor que usted que es
posible que comience una nueva carrera
por una nueva etapa de vacunas más
efectivas contra las variantes que
tenemos en la actualidad
si en el momento hay desarrollo en
nuevas plataformas de vacunas con
formulaciones distintas para las
variantes y muy probablemente en pocos
meses tengamos ya información sobre
otras casas farmacéuticas que están
diseñando vacunas para este tipo de
variantes que van a seguir circulando en
la medida que haya personas susceptibles
por eso es que la vacunación no tiene
que ser asimétrica todos tenemos que
vacunarnos y todo el mundo todo el mundo
tiene que vacunarse para lograr la
inmunidad del rival pues agradecemos al
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia asesor científico aquí
detrás 24 por esta información sobre la
posibilidad de una tercera dosis con la
vacuna de países y ustedes también
gracias por estar con nosotros entre las
24 continúen con más de nuestra página
web tras 24 punto com
[Música]